What is the CA-125 blood test?
So a CA-125 blood test is a tumor marker test.
I have a whole blog on tumor marker tests and what they mean.
Tumor marker tests were developed decades ago.
And it was in the hopes that that was going to be a great marker
for monetary to person's cancer, either the progression,
in a good way or a bad way through the treatment plan.
They are tests that are a measuring different proteins.
So they're normally found in a person's body,
but they can be expressed at a greater amount
if a person has cancer.
And if the cancer is growing and getting worse,
those tumor marker proteins can go up.
Now, there are a number of these tumor markers
that have been discovered.
Now, the truth is that they're not super accurate
as far as using them as objective data
to see whether the person is getting better or getting worse.
And if the person is undergoing chemotherapy,
it can make them even less accurate.
Because if a person's tumor is breaking up
and dying quickly, it can spill out a lot more
of these proteins in a person's tumor markers
can actually be elevated and give them a false sense
that they're getting worse when they're actually getting better.
So a lot of oncologists ceased using tumor marker tests
because of that, because they'd have to explain
to the patient that it's not a very accurate test.
Well, then why are you running it?
When I'm doing chemo, when they're explaining,
well, when you're doing chemo,
then these aren't really accurate tests.
It just gets very confusing.
So they've kind of fallen out of use.
But for a person who is wanting to monitor their cancer
in a less invasive way,
because they don't want to go and get another CT scanner.
They don't want to go and get another PET scanner.
They don't want to do those quite so often
because that involves radiation or an MRI.
They involve gadolidium or something
that can be potentially dangerous to the person's body.
We could do tumor marker blood tests
so you could get those run.
Now the pros and cons of them are,
they can bounce around a little bit.
It's not a perfect objective data.
But the truth is, if you've heard me talk about
any objective data, no objective data is perfect.
Even a gold standard PET scan isn't perfect.
Gold standard CT scan can be picking up swelling
around a cancer that is not actually growth.
It's actually in a inflammatory process
that the cancer has died.
So you have to take any objective test,
any test that you got to weigh it
with other tests that you're doing
and subject of findings to really
know whether the person is getting better
or getting worse at the progression of care.
So there's pros and cons to it.
But what are the pros of doing tumor marker tests
that is the fact that it isn't invasive?
So the non-invasiveness of doing tumor marker tests
can be super beneficial for a person
who doesn't want to go over to a PET scan
or a CT scan or something like that.
Now the other problem with them is
that some people will have a cancer
that doesn't show tumor markers.
So the thing to do is to run the test
relatively soon in your care plan.
So you know that where your baseline is.
So in our Rupa lab store,
we have a male tumor marker panel
and an email term marker panel
that tests for I think five or six tumor marker labs.
And then it's relatively inexpensive.
I think there are only about 90 bucks or something like that.
To run a tumor marker panel.
But at least you could know that you have
kind of a baseline of whether you even
show tumor markers or not.
And that gives you an idea of whether
that's going to be a good objective test for you
to continue to run it on a regular basis to see how you're doing.
But that's CA 125 is just one of those
tumor marker tests that you could look at.
So you can send it more questions
on the chat history of that.